اذا مشاهدينا اهلا بكم مجددا انا ميسون
عزام احييكم والعربيه مستمره في التغطيه
الحيه للتوترات على الحدود الاسرائيليه
اللبنانيه اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي في وقت
سابق اعتراض صواريخ اطلقت من جنوب لبنان
واعتبرت غير مسبوقه وذلك منذ حرب 2006 من
جانبه تعهد وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي
باتخاذ جميع الاجراءات لحمايه امن بلاده
فيما اعلن لبنان فتح تحقيق بالتعاون مع
اليونيفير لمعرفه الجهه المسؤوله عن اطلاق
الصواريخ الجيش اللبناني اعلنا العثور على
منصتين اطلقت منهما صواريخ فيما لم يتضح
بعد من يقف وراء هذا الهجوم قناه 12
الاسرائيليه قالت ان التقييم الامني يشير
الى وقوف فصائل فلسطينيه وراء اطلاق
الصواريخ فيما نفى مصدر مقرب من حزب الله
اي علاقه للحزب باطلاق الصواريخ مؤكدا
الروايه الاسرائيليه بان فصائل فلسطينيه
وراء الاطلاق
[موسيقى]
جماعه عم يطلعوا الصواريخ من عنا شايفين
شايفين من وين
ليكون من وين عم يطلعوا الصواريخ
[موسيقى]
ة كويس
اذا مشاهدينا في العربيه عين على الحدود
اللبنانيه الاسرائيليه وعين اخرى على ما
يحدث في فرنسا ايضا باريس والاحتجاجات
هناك الوضع لا يقل سخونه في باريس في ظل
التظاهرات التي خرجت مندده بقانون التقاعد
مطالبه بالعدول عن هذا القرار يبدو ان
هناك هنا وشات ما بين المحتجين وان وبين
القوات الامنيه الفرنسيه هذه المشاهد
شاهدناها سابقا خلال الاسابيع الماضيه
وصلت الى مناوشات وصلت الى اطلاق غاز مسيل
للدموع وايضا مواجهات مع المحتاجين على كل
هذه التظاهرات نتابعها بالتفصيل ايضا في
هذه النشره خلال هذه التغطيه ولكن في
نهايتها ولكن الان نعود لنركز على الحدود
اللبنانيه الاسرائيليه نتحدث عن التطورات
الاخيره فيما يتعلق باطلاق الصواريخ على
اسرائيل وعلى الجليل الاعلى وبالمقابل
الرد بالقذائف المدفعيه الاسرائيليه على
لبنان هل
اغلق الملف اذا مصحه تعبير ام انه الوضع
لازال
متوترا وهناك تصعيد قادم للمزيد معنا من
القدس مراسل او بالاحرى مدير مكتب العربيه
من هناك في القدس زياد حلبي اهلا بك زياد
اي جديد
طبعا لم يكن رد اسرائيلي خلافا لما اوردته
رويترز اسرائيل نفت ان تكون ردت بقذائف
مدفعيه حتى الساعه هذا الرد متوقع بدون ان
شك لكن سيكون هناك اجتماع للحكومه الامنيه
المصغره عند الثامنه والنصف بالتوقيت
المحلي مساء هذا اليوم
ستجتمع الحكومه الامنيه المصغره
لاتخاذ قرار حول طبيعه الرد التقديرات في
اسرائيل بان اسرائيل ليست بصدد ان تخوض
حربا بسبب التطور الذي جرى ولكن سيكون
هناك نوع من الرد قد يكون حتى في اكثر من
جغرافيا بمعنى اسرائيل
يعني تتهم بعناد جهاد فلسطينيه في اخر
الاتهامات وجهت اتهاما لحماس لان هي من
قامت من جنوب لبنان باطلاق رشقات الصواريخ
بالتالي سنرى ردا على الارجح في جنوب
لبنان لان الصواريخ انطلقت من هناك ولكن
من غير مستبعد ان يكون هناك غارات ايضا
على غزه بسبب انها تتهم حماسه وهكذا ورد
وفق التسريبات في اسرائيل ايا كان يبدو ان
الامور متوتره جدا لكنها تبقى قابله
للاحتواء بدون كسر قواعد اللعبه لا من حزب
الله ولا من اسرائيل في هذه المرحله طيب
وعندما نقول انه اسرائيل تتهم حماس يمكن
ان نعتمد على انه لديها معلومات مؤكده ام
قراءتها للمشهد خاصه في ظل التصعيد في
المسجد الاقصى فانه الرد هو جزء من
الرسائل
لدعم المعتكفين هناك
القراءه في اسرائيل هي بان ما يحدث منذ
ثلاث سنوات ما زال يحدث بمعنى بان هناك
وحده وحده الان بين الجبهات كلها باتت
مرتبطه بعضها ببعض بشكل مباشر
الاعتداد في المسجد الاقصى والقدس المحتله
عمليا فجر الوضع في قطاع غزه اطلق 19
صاروخا في ال 24 ساعه الماضيه وايضا في
الضفه الغربيه وصولا الى اطلاق هذه
الصواريخ من جنوب لبنان هذا السيناريو ليس
جديدا هذا حدث قبل ثلاث سنوات ايضا وقبل
سنتين بهذا المعنى ربما يكون المتغير هذه
المره هو عدد الصواريخ التي اطلقت من جنوب
لبنان تجاه منطقه الجليل
ولهذا قد يكون هناك رد اسرائيلي طبعا
اسرائيل تدعي بان البطاريات القبه
الحديديه اعترضت 25 صاروخا على الاقل فيما
سقطت خمسه صواريخ راينا اصابات
المنشات الاسرائيليه في المستوطنات مثل
شلومي حرائق اندلعت وهناك اصابه على الاقل
لاسرائيلي
لهذا عمليا الترجيحات بان يكون هناك رد
ولكن ليس بعيدا عن قواعد الاشتباك وقواعد
اللعبه المتبعه طيب
وماذا اخلاء بعض المناطق بدايه قبل حوالي
ساعتين كنا نتحدث عن مطلب اسرائيلي لمن هم
في شاطئ نهاريا لاخلاقه
هذا كان في الدقائق الاولى لاطلاق
الصواريخ هذا كان طبيعيا ان يطلب هكذا لان
صواريخ تسقط في مناطق مفتوحه ايضا سقط
صاروخان في البحر بالمناسبه ولهذا عمليا
طلب اخلاء الشواطئ هذا صحيح ومنع التجمعات
الكبيره لكن المشكله الاسرائيليه هي الاتي
ميسون اليوم هو اليوم الاول من عيد الفصح
اليهودي وهي عطله رسميه معظم الاسرائيليين
يتواجدون في المستوطنات الحدوديه الشماليه
مع لبنان وبالتالي هذا سيؤخذ بالحسبان
عندما ترد اسرائيل لهذا لا نراها تقوم
بغارات كبيره
وبحرب شامله وانما ستحاول ان تبقي في اطار
الرد طبعا ان اكتفت باطلاق عشرات القذائف
المدفعيه على جنوب لبنان وربما مغارات في
قطاع غزه قد يتم احتواء الامر بشكل سريع
ولكن ان ادخلت غارات جويه الى جنوب لبنان
هذا قد يق ود الى رد صاروخي من حزب الله
وراينا ذلك يحدث في مرات ماضيه ما يعني
يوم او يومين من القتال لا اكثر طيب على
كل سنتابع التطورات من القدس مدير مكتب
العربيه في القدس زياد حلبي شكرا جزيلا لك
ونتابع التطورات من الجانب اللبناني
مراسله العربيه غنوه يتيم معنا الان اهلا
بك غنوه اخر المعلومات لديك
قبل قليل كانت اليونسفي قد اصدرت بيان حول
ما حدث ووصفت الوضع في جنوب لبنان بالخطير
للغايه ولكنها كالعاده ايضا حثت على ضبط
النفس وتجنب المزيد من التصعيد كانت قد
اعلنت ايضا انها على تواصل مع الجانبين
اللبناني والاسرائيلي للحصول على معلومات
اكثر ايضا كان هناك معلومات عن ان الجيش
اللبناني فتح تحقيقات مع اليونيفرس من اجل
معرفه الجهه التي اطلقت هذه الصواريخ ولكن
حتى الان بحسب مصادر من الجيش اللبناني لم
يتم العثور على اي منصه لاطلاق الصواريخ
على الرغم من الانتشار الذي نفذه الجيش
اللبناني هناك دوريات مكثفه في مناطق
جنوبيه بين الجيش ومع قوات اليونسل وما
كما ذكرت هناك تحقيق فتح لتحديد هويه
المسؤولين
كان في حديث غنوه بالسابق
ربما رويترز نقلته فيما يتعلق
بان اسرائيل ردت بقذائف مدفعيه هناك نفي
لهذه التصريحات اكد هذا النفي مراسلنا
زياد حلبي وبالتالي السؤال على الجانب
اللبناني هناك تاكيدات انه لم يكن هناك اي
رد بالفعل من قبل اسرائيل بالقذائف
هناك ضغط ميسون حتى الان يعني حتى الوكاله
الرسميه في لبنان ذكرت ان هناك كان رد
مدفعي اسرائيلي ولكن بالفعل لم يكن هناك
ردمه الترجيحات تقول بانه عندما القبه
الحديديه اعترضت بعض الصواريخ سقطت بعض
الصواريخ في مناطق مفتوحه في لبنان البعض
فسرها على انها رد مدفع اسرائيلي ولكن في
الحقيقه لم يكن هناك اي رد مدفعي الجيش
اللبناني حتى الان لم يصدر اي بيان
اسرائيل اي بيان رسمي ليحدد المنطقه ليحدد
عدد الصواريخ وما ان كان هناك رد ولكن
بالفعل يعني بمجرد بان يكون الجيش
اللبناني قد
يعني نفع موضوع الرد كانت كان هذا هو
التفسير خاصه وانه يعني البعض تحدث عن
سكان الجنوب كانوا قد تحدثوا عن سقوط
صواريخ يبدو انها الصواريخ التي كان هناك
اعتراض لها من من القبه من القبه الحديديه
وكيف هي الاوضاع على الارض
انفار وماذا عن سكان تلك المناطق وان كانت
المناطق التي تم اطلاق الصواريخ منها
تعتبر مفتوحه ولكن لا شك بانها قريبه بعض
الشيء من القرى اللبنانيه
بالطبع هذه المناطق حتى وان كانت مفتوحه
هي قريبه من المنازل وهذا الامر اوضحته
الفيديوهات التي انتشرت والتي التقطتها
مواطنون بهواتفهم النقاله هناك هدوء حظر
في المناطق الجنوبيه اليونسلك كاجراء
احترازي تتخذه في كل مره كانت قد طلبت من
موظفيها النزول الى الملاجئ ولكن هذا لا
يعني بان يعني الامور
يعني ستتخذ المزيد من التصعيد هذا اجراء
تتخذه اليونسل في كل مره لا يزال هناك
اجراءات مشدده للجيش اللبناني ودوريات
مشتركه مع اليلفي خاصه وانه حتى الان لم
يتم العثور على المنصات التي اطلقت منها
الصواريخ في مرات سابقه يعني حتى الان حتى
الان حول هذه النقطه لم يتم العثور ابدا
على المنصات بحسب ما فهمت كان في امكانيه
لرفض اثنين على الاقل
هذا هذا الخبر نفاه مصدر في الجيش
اللبناني للعربيه بانه حتى الان لم يتم
العثور على منصات هذا مصدر امني ولكن كما
ذكرت حتى الان الجيش اللبناني لم يصدر اي
بيان رسمي وحتى الان ايضا لم تتخذ اي جهه
لم تعلن اي جهه في بيان لها
مسؤوليتها عن هذه عن اطلاق الصواريخ مصادر
مقربه من حزب الله نفت ان يكون حزب الله
على علاقه في مرات سابقه نعلم انه تكون
مجموعات او فصائل فلسطينيه خاصه عندما
يكون هناك بعض الاحداث في الداخل
الفلسطيني ولكن هذا بالطبع لا يعني بان
حزب الله لا يغض الطرف كونه المناطق تقع
تحت سيطرته طيب سؤال فيما يتعلق بالتحقيق
الذي تم الاعلان عن هذه ليست المره الاولى
التي يتم فيها اطلاق صواريخ من لبنان على
اسرائيل ولكن وان كان العدد اكبر هذه
المره والمده قصيره اكثر ولكن النقطه
الاساسيه بعد هذه الضربات السابقه هل كان
يكون هناك من تحقيقات وهل كان هناك من
اعلان عن النتائج لهذه التحقيقات او ماذا
وبالتالي ماذا نتوقع من هذا التحقيق
[موسيقى]
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين لاجئين الفلسطينيين
ايضا كان هناك الحادثه التي نتذكرها حادثه
قريه حصبيه عندما قام عناصر بحزب الله
بالتوجه الى مناطق خاليه في هذه القريه
ولكن تمكن السكان القريه من القبض عليهم
ومنعهم من اطلاق الصواريخ وهذه كانت المره
الوحيده التي يعني يكشف فيها حزب الله
بالجرم المشهود باطلاق هذه باطلاق هذه او
بمحاوله اطلاق هذه الصواريخ وبعدها يعني
سلم يعني تدخل الجيش والاهالي سلموا
العناصر الى للجيش اللبناني حادثه حصبيه
كانت قد حدثت بعد اسبوع
على ما اذكر من ايضا من اطلاق صواريخ من
مناطق خاليه من الجنوب اللبناني حينها
كانت المناطق بالفعل يسيطر عليها حزب الله
ولكن
الصواريخ كانت قد نص ايضا الى فصائل
فلسطينيه لكن المنطقه يعني تحدثنا حينها
بان المنطقه يسيطر عليها حزب الله ولا
يمكن ان تطلق الصواريخ من دون غط طرف نظر
حزب الله وبعدها باسبوع كان هناك حادثه
حصبيه والقاء القبض على عناصر من حزبه
وغنوه حول هذه النقطه تحديدا ذكرت ايضا
قبل قليل انه لم يتم فرض اجراءات تمنع
تكرار ما حدث سابقا من قبل الجيش اللبناني
طبيعه الاجراءات التي كانت مرجوه وهل
بالفعل هو قادر على التحرك باريحيه في تلك
المناطق
طبعا الجيش اللبناني هو غير قادر على
التحرك في مناطق يسيطر عليها حزب الله
الجهات المعارضه او الجهات التي تنادي الى
بناء دوله وسيطره الجيش بالفعل على الحدود
هي هي تطالب بان يكون هناك
دوريات اكثر بان تضبط هذه المناطق الخاليه
بطريقه ما حتى وان كانت
يعني مناطق طويله ساحليا ولكن يمكن ولكن
يمكن ضبطها بعض الشيء ان كان هناك قرار
فعلي حزب الله يمكنه ضبطها اذا اراد لانه
خاصه بانه يسيطر على هذه المناطق الجيش
اللبناني اكثر يعمل مع اليونسل على على
الخط الازرق هي هذه المناطق تقع بعيده بعض
الشيء عن عن الخط الازرق ولكن لا يمكن
يعني كما ذكرت كان يمكن هناك ان تتخذ بعض
الاجراءات ان كان عبر وضع حواجز في
المناطق او او تسيير دوريات بشكل اكبر
ولكن هذا الامر ايضا قد لا يتمكن الجيش من
من اتخاذه
بشكل يمكنه اتخاذه فيها خاصه وان هذه
المناطق يسيطر عليها حزب الله كان معنا من
بيروت مراسله العربيه غنوه يتيم ابقي معنا
غنوه ساعود اليك في سياق هذه النشره ولكن
اسمحي لي ان انتقل الان الى ضيفه من
بروكسل للدكتور رمضان ابو جزر مدير مركز
بروكسل الدوله للبحوث وايضا معي من بيروت
علي الامين رئيس تحرير موقع الجنوبيه
وابدا معك استاذ علي تعليق اولي على ما
حدث اليوم
يعني بدايه لابد من القول انه في حرص من
جميع الاطراف على الاقل ظاهره حتى الان هو
المحافظه على قواعد الاشتباك اتحدث هنا عن
لبنان
اتحدث عن حزب الله واسرائيل
لا شك انه الرد الاسرائيلي حتى الان على
اطلاق الصواريخ لم
يحصل كما
كما قيل وهناك ربما تكون ضربات ونحن
اعتدنا في فترات سابقه ان تقوم باسرائيل
بتوجيه مجموعه ضربات يعني غايتها القول ان
الضربه الاخيره لها وهو رد محدود لا تريد
من خلاله الذهاب الى مواجهه عاليه مواقف
حزب الله او حتى ايضا بالطريقه التي عبر
عنها انه لو كان هو صائما اطلق الصاروخ
والصواريخ لما كان الامر تم بهذه الطريقه
وبالتالي هو يريد ان يقول ايضا يريد ان
يحافظ على قواعد الاشتباك ولا يريد
التصعيد تملص الاطراف جميعها من تبني
مساله الصواريخ هو يخدم هذه الاطراف من
جهه ويخدم اسرائيل من جهه ثانيه ان لا
تكون في موقع
محرج بمعنى اذا تبنى حزب الله مثلا او
تبنت
حماس او تبين اتمنى اي طرف معين فاسرائيل
سترد مباشره على هذا الطرف وبالتالي
اعتدنا نحن في فترات سابقه ان يتم اطلاق
صواريخ وان لا تتبنى جهه احيانا تظهر
مجموعه معينه ولكن هي المجموعه يعني لا
تكون موجوده بالمعنى الفعلي يعني فقط هي
نوع من اصدار بيان لتتبني مجموعه ما لكن
واضح ان الامور برايي وان كنا نحن في ظروف
يعني كل الاحتمالات وارده نحن نتعامل مع
بس عندي سؤال فيما يتعلق بموقف حزب الله
واعلانه بانه لا علاقه له باطلاق الصواريخ
هل تتفق مع من يقرا بالشارع اللبناني انه
لا يمكن لمثل هذه الصواريخ ان تنطلق من
الجنوب اللبناني دون على الاقل ان لم يكن
قرار على الاقل ضوء احمر اخضر عذرا من حزب
الله
التحصيل حاصل يعني مع اي عاقل نحكي بشكل
يعرف انه هذه الامور لا يمكن ان تتم بدون
بدون يعني ضوء اخضر من حزب الله وبالتالي
حتى الى حد ما يعني من اداره حزب الله
للموضوع يعني ليس حزب الله فقط
بتقديره ايضا يعني لا يسمح بان تطلق مثل
هذه الصواريخ بل لم يكن هو الذي يديرا مثل
هذه العمليات لانه هذا يخلي بدوره وبنفوذه
وبسيطرته على هذه المنطقه وهذا امر ليس
مرتبطا فقط يعني بجمهوري والى ذلك هو لديه
التزامات دوليه ايضا في هذا الاتجاه وهذه
هي النقطه الاساسيه اللي بحب احكي عنها
فيما يتعلق بالتوقيت ولكن اسمح لي ان
نستمع الى راي ضيفي ايضا من بروكسل دكتور
رمضان حول قراءته للمشهد وان كان بالفعل
يؤيد وجهه النظر التي تقول بانه لا احد
يريد كسر قواعد اللعبه وبالتالي الوضع حتى
هذه اللحظه بما نشاهده من رد فعل
الاسرائيلي يمكن احتوائه
مساء الخير
بالفعل نفي حزب الله المسؤوليه عن نفسه
بشكل مباشر وواضح يؤكد على تمسك حزب الله
بالتهدئه مع دوله الاحتلال وايضا اسرائيل
حصلت على ما ارادت او حكومه نتنياهو حصلت
على ما ارادت من خلال اطلاق هذه الصواريخ
دون تحقيق اي خسائر تؤثر على الامن
الاسرائيلي او
الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي هذه 100 صاروخ اطلقت
في اقل من عشر دقائق بطريقه مفاجئه لم
تحدث اي خسائر ماديه او بشريه وفي نفس
الوقت يعني اسرائيل عندما نقول انه اصيب
شخص هذا هو خبر عندما نتحدث عن
محطه وقود نشاهد النيران تخرج منها ونشاهد
ايضا صور
اثار هذه القذائف بالنسبه
للشارع الاسرائيلي لن تكون مقبوله ابدا
وخاصه في ظل الانقسام الذي شاهدناه
بالفتره الماضيه انت تقول اسرائيل مستفيده
مستفيده فقط انه الخسائر ليست بالكبيره او
في استفادات اخرى تجعل ربما من تبعات مثل
هذه الضربات للشارع ان يتوحد على الاقل
بعد المشاهد التي شاهدناها في الشارع قبل
ايام
هذا ما اردت الذهاب اليه ان الاستفاده
الكبرى لاسرائيل بعد الضغط الضغط الدولي
على حكومه نتنياهو بعد
حاله الشرع الاسرائيلي وحاله الانقسام
وحاله التشردم هذه الهجوم هذا الهجم بهذا
الهجوم بهذه الحجم بالذات يسمح بتوحيد
الجبهه الداخليه الاسرائيليه من جديد يسمح
لحكومه نتنياهو بفرض رؤيتها ومحاصره
معارضيها وتحت ظل صوت المعركه يعلو على كل
على اي صوت اعتقد ان المستفيد الاكبر من
هذه الصواريخ هي حكومه نتنياهو حيث يتسنى
يتسنى لبن غفير الان لاستفراد بسكان القدس
وتنفيذ ارادته على الاقصى كما يريد اما
الحديث عن حزب الله ومسؤوليته حزب الله لا
اعتقد انه يسعى لمواجهه مع اسرائيل فهو
يؤمن حدود اسرائيل منذ اكثر من 15 او سبعه
عشر عاما دون اي فاتوره تدفعها اسرائيل في
حدودها الشماليه في مواجهه حزب الله
يمكن ان لا نسقط سيناريو ان تكون صفقه بين
جهات استخباراتيه اسرائيليه وجهات اخرى
مستفيده من حرف الانظار عما يحدث في
اسرائيل او بعض الجهات التي لا لا يروق
لها الاتفاق بين ايران والسعوديه التي
ترعاه الصين ان يلقي بظلاله على لبنان
يمكن وضع هذا في هذا الاطار ولكن المستفيد
الاكبر مما حدث هو حكومه نتنياهو في
مواجهه الفلسطينيين في مواجهه خصومها
السياسيين في اسرائيل في مواجهه الشارع
الاسرائيلي وفي مواجهات الغضب الدولي
والامريكي بالذات
نستمع الى ضيفي طبعا استاذ علي الامين حول
هذه النقطه تحديدا رؤيه لم
مستفيد من الخاسر الاكبر عندما نتحدث عن
هذا التوقيت الصراحه على المستوى الاقليمي
هناك عده تحولات ذكر منها بعضها ضيفه
وايضا لا يمكن لنا ان نتجاهل ما يحدث في
سوريا من استهدافات ايضا وبالتالي اين
يمكن تصويب رد الفعل هذا اذا ما كانت
فصائل فلسطينيه قد قامت به او حزب الله
ادارها او غيره كيف بتقرا المشهد وهل يمكن
ربطه فقط في هذه المرحله بما يحدث من
انتهاكات في المسجد الاقصى او لا الموضوع
اكبر من ذلك بكثير وله اكثر من روايه
بالتاكيد يعني هلا من الصعب ان نحصر
تداعيات والنتائج اللي ممكن ان يؤديها ما
جرى لكن على الاقل فينا نشير الى موضوع
الاقصى وهو موضوع يثير الاهتمام وبالتالي
يخلق نوع من التفاعل ليس على المستوى
الفلسطيني مع المستوى العربي والاسلامي
وانا برايي هذا ايضا اثر سلبا على على
اسرائيل بمعنى اسرائيل التي كانت تطمح ان
يعني ان تلقى دائما نوع من الاحتضان
العربي
المس بعمليه القدس بالتالي له تاثير سلبي
حتى على عمليات التطبيع اللي عم تجري او
لجرد جزء منها وله تاثير ونحن ننظر الان
الى الموصل الاردني فيما يتصل في التعامل
مع احداث الاقصى في جانب لا شك له تاثير
سلبي على اسرائيل وبالتالي اسرائيل لا
يمكن ان تقوم بعمليات عسكريه كبرى نتيجه
الصواريخ التي اطلقت اخيرا ايضا لاعتبار
من الاعتبارات وهذا الاعتبار
المناخ الاقليمي ليس مساعد لاسرائيل في
هذا الاتجاه بطبيعه الحال حزب الله يدرك
هذا الامر والقوى وحماس والقوى الفلسطينيه
او فصل تدرك هذا الجانب وتستثمر في هذا
الجانب وهذا هناك عمليه استثمار لمزيد من
الاستقطاب على الاقل ففي محلله تبرير هذا
الوجود العسكري والامني لكن انا مع
المقوله التي تقول بنهايه الامر انه لا شك
انه هناك حرص على المحافظه على قواعد
الاشتباك حسبي الله لا يريد التصعيد حزب
الله يدرك انه يقف على ارض تهتز على
المستوى اللبناني وحتى على المستوى
الاقليمي وهو يدرك ان هناك مخاطر كبرى
لذلك هو حريص جدا على ان يحافظ على الهدوء
والاستقرار في جنوب لبنان وفيما يتعلق
بعدم الذهاب الى تصعيد في شمال اسرائيل
لانه كل ذلك نحن لانه امام محطه مفصليه في
هذه المرحله تفترض الى حد ما عدم الخطا
على الاقل بين متزوجين او القيام باي خطوه
ناقصه فيما يتصل في
المواجهه او في يعني خلق ارباك على الحدود
الجنوبيه ويجب النظر دائما الى انه ترسيم
الحدود البحريه بين لبنان واسرائيل يعطي
اشاره ورانزيه كبيره ومهمه على المسار
المستقبل فيما يتصل بالهدوء والاستقرار
على هذه المنطقه وهذا انطلاقا من مصلحه
حزب الله في هذا الامر والمصلحه الايرانيه
بدرجه اساسيه بانه لا تريد الذهاب الى
تصعيد يبقى ان نقول انه لبنان ايضا في
الوضعيه التي هو عليها اليوم اقتصاديا
وماليا وكل يعرف يحصل ولا يستحمل اي
مغامره صغيره في ولو كانت يعني بحدود
احتمالات الخطر تكون قليله لكن لا يمكن
اللبنانيين ان يقبلوا بان تكون هناك
مغامره لا باسم فصائل فلسطينيه ولا باسم
حزب الله ولذلك لاحظنا على الاقل هم
يدركون ذلك لكل حاول ان يتملص من هذه
المسؤوليه لكن رب الان الامر ساعد بانه
اسرائيل
غير يعني مستعده للرد لكن قد لا يكون
الامر في مرحله في مره اخرى
وهذا وهذا سيكون له نتائج خطيره اذا كان
هذا هو الوضع ولا احد يستطيع ان يتحمل اي
رد فعل من اي جهه كيف يمكن للسلطات
اللبنانيه ان تتحرك على الارض ان كان فيما
يتعلق بالفصائل الفلسطينيه او حزب الله
هذا سؤال نضعه على الطاوله لنطرحه بعد
قليل لكن اسمح لي ان انتقل للدكتور رمضان
للحديث عن
اذا كانت اسرائيل هي المستفيد الاول
والاخير لاحظنا حتى الان ليس هناك لا اعلم
ان كانت الولايات المتحده في سبات الان
وبالتالي لم نستمع الى رد فعل حتى الان
ولكن نحن نعلم ان العلاقه لم تعد ورديه
كما كانت بين الولايات المتحده واسرائيل
تبعات مثل هذه الضربات على هذه العلاقه
كيف نتوقعها
لا نتوقع ان تتخلل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه عن اسرائيل مهما كانت الخلافات
السياسيه او خلافات البيت الابيض مع من
يحكم في تل ابيب هذا غير متوقع ونتوقع ان
تقدم دائما الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الدعم لحمايه اسرائيل
ولكن
في هذا الهجوم الذي نعتبره تنفيس وليس
مواجهه
[موسيقى]
في الماضي ولا زال يعني احنا نستفيد هلا
احيانا هناك جهات في حزب الله غاضبه جدا
من التوافق الايراني السعودي وتريد ان
تخلط الاوراق من جديد هناك جهات اخرى هناك
لاعبين اخرى لا يجب ان نكون ساذجين يجب ان
النيه احيانا لكي نصل الى تحليل واقعي
للاوضه ما حدث في الاقصى هو محرك يمكن ان
يحرك
الفصائل الفلسطينيه كان يمكن
على الاتفاق الايراني السعودي هلا هو
توقيت ضربات جاءت في وقت مناسب ربما اذا
كان هذا هو الاطار او العنوان الرئيسي
استغلال العامل الديني وتغول اسرائيل
وهجومها على المقدسات وقبلها باسابيع خطاب
اسرائيلي من مترش في باريس يهين الاردن
ويهين الدول الاقليم ويستعدي على الامه
العربيه وجاءت احداث مسجد الاقصى التي
حركت مشاعر المسلمين هي فرصه مواتيه
لاطلاق الصواريخ حتى من البحر او من اي
جهه لخلط الاوراق هناك جهات داخل حزب الله
لا يروق لها الاتفاق السعودي الايراني لان
عليه تبعات كثيره وسوف يفقد الكثير منهم
استفادات كثيره منهم الوضع في لبنان لا
يحتمل اي مواجهه ولكن ليس من المقبول في
كل مره تحتد الامور وتختلط الامور في جنوب
لبنان او في غيرها يتم تحميل المسؤوليه
للعامل الفلسطيني هذه المره يسعت اطراف
لبنانيه كثيره وخاصه المقربين من حز ان
يشير بشكل غير مباشر الى اصابع الاتهام ان
جهات فلسطينيه اوصال فلسطينيه هي التي
قامت في اسبقيه بهذا الاطار ولكن طبعا
سننتظر التحقيق لانه حتى الان كلها مصادر
تتحدث عن وطبعا نفي من حزب الله بنفسه ان
يكون له اي علاقه بذلك هذه التصريحات
رسميه سننتظر معرفه المزيد وايضا نتائج
نتمنى ان نستمع نتائج التحقيقات الدكتور
رمضان ابو جزر مدير مركز بروكسل الدولي
للبحوث شكرا جزيلا لك واعود اليك سيد علي
لاتطرق الى النقطه التي كنت اتحدث عنها عن
الدور الذي يمكن ان يقوم به الجيش
اللبناني لوقف مثل هذه العمليات بغض النظر
عن من قام بها الجانب الفلسطيني الجانب
الجانب حزب الله او حتى لو كانت صفقه كما
ذكر ضيفه قبل قليل ربما من الاستخبارات
الاسرائيليه وغيرها
يعني كنت اشرت قبل
قبل قليل لانه في كثير من الاحيان ماذا ما
هي النتائج التي يعني حصلت بعد اطلاق
صواريخ في فترات سابقه او هل تم القبض على
تحقيقات
بتقديري يعني هذا المسار يكشف على الاقل
بالنسبه لي بانه ليس هناك من يعني بمعنى
التعامل الحازم مع هكذا مجموعات وليس هناك
من القول واضح ونهائي بانه هم ضد اطلاق
الصواريخ من جنوب لبنان والا كان الامر تم
يعني التعامل مع مثل هذه العمليات بطريقه
مختلفه عما يتم عليه اليوم لذلك اقول انه
الجيش اللبناني اليوم من الصعب ان نتحدث
عن دور خارج الاطار الذي يضعه يتضعه مطله
حزب الله الامنيه في تلك المنطقه
الامسانيه والعسكريه الجيش اللبناني لا
يمكن له ان يتجاوز الخطوط الحمراء التي
يضعها حزب الله وبالتالي ايضا الجيش
اللبناني الا حد كبير ولا اريد ان اجزم
بشكل نهائي وكامل الى حد كبير هو يدرك ان
هذه منطقه ان السيطره النهائيه هي لحزب
الله ويحاول ان ينسق ما حزب الله في هذا
الامر وان لا يذهب الى اي محاوله اصطدام
دون ان يعني نغيب عن بين المتابع والمشاهد
لانه في كثير من المواقع العسكريه داخل
المؤسسه العسكريه ايضا موجوده ومعينه من
قبل حزب الله ليست خارج تاثير لا اقول ان
كلا لكن الى حد كبير لا يمكن ان يعين
مسؤول المنطقه الفلانيه في الجنوب او في
منطقه بدون ان يكون هناك موافقه مع الاسف
يمكن نصل بكلامنا الى هذا المستوى ولكن
هذا يعني قد يكون في لحظه ما امر قره اليه
بالحكومه الدولي الجيش اللبناني لكن هذا
يدل في نهايه الامر على مسار تدميري
تدميري ونحن نشهد احد اثاره وتداعيته على
المستوى الوطني سواء على مستوى الدوله
وهذا النموذج الذي شهدناه على مستوى
الدوله بانه تم اختراقها وتفكيك مؤسسات
الدوله وعلى المستوى الامني للاجهزه
الامنيه اصبحت يعني في وضعيه الى حد كبير
يرثى لها وحتى الجيش اللبناني اليوم لا
يمكن ان يكون مستقلا بشكل فعلي وكامل
وبالتالي هذه نتائج هذا السلوك السياسي
وهذه المسارات اودى بلبنان الى ما هو عليه
اليوم النقطه المحوريه الاساسيه الثمن
الذره التاج الاساسيه هي الحفاظ على
الاستقرار في شمال اسرائيل وجنوب لبنان هي
حزب الله يدرك اهميتها ويدرك انها النقطه
التي يحتاجها الجميع ويتمسك
له الاقليمي والدولي امريكا تريد هذا
الاستقرار اسرائيل تريد هذا الاستقرار دول
اوروبيه تريد هذا الاستقرار
ماذا عن ايران
ايران ايران تستثمر ايضا بان لديها قوه
على حدود اسرائيل وتساهم في الاستقرار
وبالتالي هي اعطت الضوء الاخضر لترسيم
الحدود واعطت لاسرائيل ضوء اخضر بانه تطلع
الغاز من كاريش ما كان ليتم ذلك الامر لو
يملك كل ايران دور في هذا الامر فبالتالي
ايران لها دور بهذا المعنى وحزب الله ينفذ
هذا الى حد ما يعني مش لحد كبير ينفذ
بالله هاي متطلبات الايرانيه في هذه
المرحله ولذلك اهميه حزب الله دوليا
واقليميا في هذه المنطقه وهو يدرك انه
الاهميه هي في المحافظه على الاستقرار
الان الجميع يريد هذا الاستقرار لذلك لن
يسمح بان تخرج العمليات سواء اطلاق
الصواريخ كان هو مطلقا عن حدود لا تؤدي
الى استدراج الى حرب متل ما قال كمان
الضيف سابق انه بالنهايه ممكن
الاسرائيليين يستفيدوا منها وحزب الله
يستفيد منها والفصل الفلسطينيه تستفيد
منها في اللعب السياسيه بالتالي القائمه
اليوم في البعض كان يتحدث عن
المازق الذي ربما رغم الاستفاده اللي عم
نحكي عنها ربما تكون لاسرائيل من خلال هذه
الضربات على المستوى الداخلي ولكن البعض
يقول انه نتنياهو الان ربما يكون في مازق
لانه اذا رد فربما سيفتح الباب لمجالات لا
يريدها احد كما كنت قد ذكرت لا من الجانب
الاسرائيلي ولا من الجانب اللبناني او على
المستوى الاقليمي والدولي ولكن بالمقابل
اذا لم يرد فبالتالي هناك شارع غاضب اصلا
من نتنياهو وبالتالي كيف له ان يحفظ ماء
الوجه بهذه الفتره برايك اسرائيل دائما
بكل العمليات العسكريه راقده لكل الحروب
وكل الضربات الاسرائيلي الضربه الاخيره
تكون لاسرائيل هذه الجيش الاسرائيلي لا
يسمح بان يتم الخروج عليها وبالتالي نحن
نتوقع بطبيعه الحال ان يكون هناك رد
اسرائيلي الرد الاسرائيلي
ليس هناك من طرف اعلى مسئوليته عن هذه
الصواريخ يعني لا حزب الله قال انا مسؤول
لا حماس سالت انا مسؤول ولا اي جهه اخرى
قالت انا مسؤوله عن هذه الصواريخ بدا يخفف
العبئ عن نتنياهو بمعنى ان يكون الرد ليس
بالضروره يعني لو قال حزبره انا مسؤول عن
هذه الصواريخ بالتاكيد هذا سيحرج نتنياه
وسيذهب بماتني لا بنضطر ان يواجه ضربه
قويه او كانت حماس عدم اعلان اي طرف
مسؤوليته عن هذه العمليه هذا برايي يساهم
في التهدئه يساهم بالتهدئه بس اذا كان
استاذ علي الامين وانت كما ذكرت قبل قليل
انه اسرائيل يجب ان تكون لها الضربه
الاخيره وبالتالي اذا لم يكن هناك من جهه
لتعلن مسؤوليتها عن هذه العاده هذه
الحادثه وبالمقابل ايضا ذكرت قبل قليل
وكان في تعليق على قضيه التحقيقات بانها
لا تجدي نفعا اين ستتوجه اسرائيل ما هي
الخارطه الميدانيه التي يمكن ان تتحرك
فيها وهل يمكن يكون الرد بسوريا مثلا
الارجح هي سوريا اساسا يوميا في ضربات بس
الارجح انا برايي انه بدي تنظر لكن ضربه
محدوده لن تستدرج مواجهات نحن شفنا
بالفترات سابقه في لبنان
صواريخ او عمليات فكانت توجه اما يعني
بضربات مدفعيه او ما الى ذلك ممكن تكون
اكثر من تنغاره معينه ولكن الهدف الاساسي
ان تقول اسرائيل انها ردت على هذه العمليه
وانها يعني لم تسكت وبالتالي هي صاحبه
الضرب الاخيره لكن ليس الى الحد الذي يمكن
ان يستدرج رد مقابل وهذا دائما كان عم
بيصير برايي نحن اليوم في هذه المرحله في
هذا المناخ في موضوع السوري اساسا ممكن
يعني انا ارى انه احد اسباب الضرب اللي
حصلت او الصواريخ قد يكون في وجه من
وجوهها هو انه حزب الله وايران يتعرضان من
يوميا شبه يوميا بالاونه الاخيره
فقط اربعه بطلع لحزب الله
مسؤولين ايرانيين ولا يقوم حزب الله ولا
ايران بالرد على اسرائيل وهذا كان امر
محرج برايي له على الاقل لدى المؤيدين
والبيئه المحيطه بهم
تقديري ما حصل في لبنان احد او جه مبرراته
هو محاوله القول لهذه البيئه وهذا الجمله
مهما قادرين نرد على اسرائيل ولو بالطريقه
التي حصلت انه تعويض عن الصمت المدام من
قبل الجمهور حزب الله انه كيف يضرب ويقتل
الناس في سوريا وبالتالي يوميا ضربات
اسرائيليه وما عم بتردوا فبالتالي هون
برايي اعطت فرصه هيك متنفس لحزب الله بانه
يقول ايضا نحن نستطيع قادرين ان نرد
وبجنوب لبنان حصل هذا الامر لكن بالحدود
التي يعني اثرنا اليها بما لا يتجاوز وبما
لا يدفع الامور الى مسارات
ابقى معنا سيد علي مع ضيف الان يبدو من
القدس المحلي السياسي لنيسان اليه نشاهد
هذه الصور للاضرار في بعض المستوطنات
قراءتك للمشهد وهل مثل هذه الصور بالنسبه
لاسرائيل لا تدفع نتنياهو للرد بصوره قويه
وتصعيد اكثر يمكن بالفعل كما يقول العديد
من المحللين احتواء الموقف ولا احد لا من
الجانب الاسرائيلي او اللبناني يريد كسر
قواعد اللعبه
فعلا انه منذ عام 2006 لا لا اسرائيل ولا
منظمه حزب الله اشعال المنطقه ولكن اليوم
ما حدث اطلاق اربعه وتلاتين صاروخا باتجاه
شمال اسرائيل
هذا لم يكن ربما
بايحاء او
بتنفيذ منظمه حزب الله وانما هذا كان
بايحاء منظمه حزب الله وايران لاشعال كافه
الجبهات اذا كان في اورشليم واذا كان من
من لبنان مع العلم ان حركه حماس التي هي
ربما والفصائل الفلسطينيه التي تقف وراء
اطلاق هذه الصواريخ طبعا وانا ارجع الى
هذا الموضوع باهام منظمه حزب الله نرى ان
الحدود في قطاع غزه حركه حماس تريد مواصله
التهدئه في قطاع غزه واشعال الفتنه
صحيح ان حركه حماس هي التي اشعلت بواسطه
التحريض ان هناك عناصر او جهات اسرائيليه
تريد المساس بمكانه الحرم القدسي فيها
الصور تشهد
صور تشهد على ما يحدث من انتهاكات
وضرب مباشر ومبرح للفلسطينيين
السلميين لا يحملون السلاح ولكن لا اريد
الخوض الان في تفاصيل ما يحدث من انتهاكات
اسرائيليه بالداخل
لا ما بدي ترد على هذه النقطه خلينا نحكي
على قراءه في المشهد العام فيما يتعلق
بالضربات الصاروخيه هذه هل هي مرتبطه
برايك بالداخل او مرتبطه بتطورات اقليميه
اكثر
اذا تسمحي لي ارد لان اسئلتك اطول من
الجواب تبعي اذا اقول هكذا
منظمه حزب الله شعرك بعد
الاتفاق الاقليمي في بحر الابيض ان
اسرائيل لا تريد
تصغير الاوضاع ومن هنا اسرائيل تنازلت على
مساحات اقليميه في البحر الابيض لصالح
لبنان ثانيا منذ اتفاق
1901 راينا في الاونه الاخيره ان منظمه
حزب الله التي يمنع منها ان تكون ان
تترابا في جنوب لبنان ان عناصر حزب الله
نزلت طبعا الى جنوب لبنان واقامت العديد
من المواقع على الحدود على التماس مع
اسرائيل
قدمت اكم شكوى ضد هذه الضواهر
للامم المتحده قوات الامم المتحده
المرابطه في جنوب لبنان مع الاسف هذه
القوات لم تعمل شيئا بهذا الموضوع ولا
اعرف ما مدى نجاعه وجدوى تواصل تواجد هذه
القوات في جنوب لبنان واقول ان اسرائيل لا
تريد في الوقت الحاضر
اشعال المنطقه مع حزب الله وترد اسرائيل
لا شك ان اطلاق 34 صاروخا باتجاه شمال
اسرائيل هذا اجتياز كل الخطوط الحمراء منذ
عام 2006 ولذلك اسرائيل اذا وجهت الضربه
ترد ضربه في جنوب لبنان وليس في لبنان كما
قلت هدف
كان اطول من سؤالي ولكنك حتى بكل طول هذا
الجواب لم تجب على سؤالي فيما يتعلق بانه
الرساله المباشره من اين
طولت كثير كان عندك الوقت تجاوب بس عندي
نقطه مهمه جدا الا تحرج هذه الصور التي
نشاهدها لهذه الاضرار نتنياهو الان خاصه
في ظل الانقسام الذي شاهدناه في الشارع
الاسرائيلي وما يقال عن صوره اهتزت
لاسرائيل فيما يتعلق بقوه الردع لديها
صحيح ان هناك كان في الاسابيع الاخيره
انقسام في المجتمع الاسرائيلي
وربما المظاهرات اذا لم يكن تطور امني
في يوم السبت بعد يومين اذا لم يكن تطور
في شوارع تل ابيب بعد الموضوع
صحيح ان يوم امس وقبل يوم امس كانت صواريخ
من قطاع غزه بشكل خاص ليله امس واسرائيل
لم ترد على هذا الموضوع ولكن عندما تتعرض
اسرائيل على مخاطر لا يكون هناك اي علامه
استفهام بهذا الموضوع بان الامن
الاسرائيلي يتعرض وعنده نتنياهو واجهزه
الامن وعلى راسهم وزير الدفاع
ورئيس اركان جيش الدفاع يترددون من توجيه
ضربه لكل من قام الصواريخ انت اشرت اكثر
من مره لحزب الله وبالمقابل المصادر
الاسرائيليه الرسميه تتحدث عن انه الفصائل
الفلسطينيه هي من قامت بهذه الخطوه اما
خوفا واستحياء من ان تضطر لمواجهه حزب
الله والرد المباشر او لديها معلومات
انا قلت ان من قام
من قام بهذه الفعله هي الفصائل الفلسطينيه
بايحاء حركه حماس وراينا صالح العروري
واسماعيل الهنيه الذين اجتمعاها في الايام
الاخيره مع حسن نصر الله وكان هناك تنسيق
بين كافه هذه الجهات ربما لم تقوم منظمه
حزب الله بهذه الفعله ولكن هي على علم بما
يحدث بكل نقطه ونقطه في جنوب لبنان واذا
ارادت منظمه حزب الله منع من اطلاق هذه
الصواريخ اذا كانت تعمل ذلك ولكن منظمه
حزباء ارادت ارادت بواسطه هذه الفعله انها
تقوم انها ايضا طرف في النزاع الاسرائيلي
الفلسطيني بما يحدث في حرم القدس الشريف
وانها لن تقف مكتوفه الايدي بهذا الموضوع
فهمنا النقطه اللي عم تقولها بس النقطه
الرئيسيه انه من خلال كلامك افهم انه
اسرائيل لم يكن لها ان تتفاجا من هذه
الضربه من خلال قراءتك للتحركات الاخيره
لكان لحماس او لحزب الله كان من المفترض
ان تكون مستعده لمثل هذه الضربه
كيف تعلمين انها اسرائيل لم تكن مستعده
على هذه الضربه العلم ان وزير انا اقول لك
اذا انت على على كافه المعلومات انا وزير
الدفاع الذي ظهر يوم امس منصه اطلاق
الصواريخ في جنوب لبنان في جنوب اسرائيل
او عزاء لكافه القوات اذا كان في جنوب
جنوب اسرائيل واذا كان في شمال اسرائيل ان
تكون على اهبه الاستعداد لاي طارئ وراينا
انه معظم هذه الصواريخ التي اطلقت 34
معظمها تم اعتراضها صحيح انه لم يكن مئه
بالمئه واحد الصواريخ سقطت في قفص دجاج
وربما ادت الى
محطه وقود تحترق نشاهد هذه الصور لسيارات
واضرار في المحل التجاريه واصابه مستوطن
من القدس كان معنا المحلل السياسي
الينيسان